oh you knew I was gonna have to come
back to this stuff you know we're always
away from new Doctor Who episodes but I
still like to talk about it and I
figured out some more list that I can
pop your way I'm gonna list the top ten
stories for the ninth tenth and eleventh
Doctor's a reminder for the way I do
this I count two parters as a single
story case you're wondering why I'm only
doing 9 10 11 it's because I haven't
seen everything of the other doctors and
I don't feel that it's fair for me to
try and do a top ranked when there are
episodes I haven't seen in the case of
some of the older doctors huge swathes
of their stuff that I haven't seen I
think I've got a pretty decent knowledge
of the classic era but not enough to do
that kind of list on those doctors not
yet it anyway I may get to it quick
warning on this I am gonna talk about
these episodes very freely so consider
that spoiler warning but we're gonna
start with the ninth doctor Christopher
Eccleston and you remember how I
mentioned I count two partners as one
story well since I do that that actually
means there are only ten stories for the
ninth doctor which means I'm just gonna
rank all of them in order so starting at
the bottom we have Father's Day I know
what this episode was trying to go for
and I get the emotional weight that they
wanted to have but for me it just didn't
work
roses whole thing with her father for me
it felt like it came out of nowhere it
didn't feel properly built up and
established she went so harshly against
what the doctor had been telling her she
couldn't couldn't do it just made me
annoyed with her as a character what the
ultimate resolution of the episode was
gonna end up being I saw coming
basically as soon as she pushed him out
of the way that the episode was gonna
have to end with Pete dying I mean that
was obvious so that it wasn't a buildup
who's just me waiting okay when are they
finally gonna realize that's what has to
happen and it didn't help that the
Reapers really just felt like a ripoff
of the Langille ears and you know what
it wasn't a great idea when Stephen King
did it either
moving up the list number 9 the unquiet
dead I don't have as many sort of issues
with this one as I have with father's
days it was just kind of a dull episode
for me nothing really clicked on the
level that it should have I mean yeah
the guy who's playing Charles Dickens is
fine there's nothing wrong with him and
the settings okay I guess but it was
sort of it's
right off the bat it started my not
being particularly big fan of the
historical episodes dealing with famous
people and that sort of started right
off the bat with this again it's not a
horror bump so but this there's really
nothing that I can point to whenever I'm
like that that's the best moment in that
episode is just it just is number eight
the long game now again a bit of a doll
episode but there's enough things in
this episode that I like that I'm gonna
put it above the others one being Simon
Pegg and honestly I'm biased I just like
Simon Pegg I'll completely cop to that
but I also actually really liked the use
of atom as a completely crap companion
as a way to sort of highlight why Rose
is actually a decent companion and at
that point I kind of needed that because
I was having a hard time sort of going
with why is the doctor with her why does
he ditch her and find somebody better oh
ok not everybody can handle this cool I
mean the overall story is OK it's decent
the jagrafess is a bit of a toss away I
talk about him when I did my worst
villains list so it's not a great
episode but there are enough little
highlights in it that you know I'll
still go back and watch it again
number 7 aliens in London and World War
3 two-parter and there's some highs and
some lows in this one and that's we
won't go higher because the lows do drag
it down a bit and the lows largely have
to do with this Lavigne with both the
design I don't like the baby-faced
design on them and the farting just the
why would the farming that set as much
as that stuff just sort of bothers me I
think the doctor has some of his best
moments when he gets angry at the
soldier for shooting the pig and
creature and just yelling at the soldier
it was scared or when he's just standing
there and they're throwing information
about the Saleen at him he's just going
narrows it down
narrows it down and he's just taking the
information and filtering until he gets
to his answer I love that I mean that's
really what pulls up this episode
Christopher Eccleston has some of his
best moments and best stuff in this
episode and while it does not completely
negate the stuff that isn't as good it
doesn't work as well it does lift the
whole experience up a bit number 6
boomtown here we have again with the
slippy thankfully the party was toned
down a little bit
get something but quieter a bit more
intimate and I like the back-and-forth
between the doctor and the one remaining
Slovene I like that interaction I like
that relationship I like how she sort of
coaxes out the doctors darkness a little
bit so I like about and all those
moments the conclusion is been a little
weird a little cheesy and the episode
itself doesn't feel like it has a ton of
lasting impact but I like the overall
vibe of it
number five rose again largely buoyed by
Christopher Eccleston now honestly
Christopher Eccleston had sold me almost
as soon as he was on the screen really
the moment where I was completely on
board and going this guy is terrific at
the moment after he gets rose out of the
building then he opens the new game pops
his head back out he's holding the bomb
yes sir her name he goes nice to meet
you rose
run for your life and just that fun in
that sort of joy in the adventure I
really loved and again Eccleston himself
is really what lifts this episode up
because and this episode did not sell
Rose to me particularly well and the use
of the Autons the Nestene is decent it
works okay but there's also some goofy
stuff the garbage can eating Mickey is
weird and kind of cartoonish but you
know the doctor you know holding Rose's
hand and you know talking about what he
is experiencing just standing there it
just really works and as I said the
other who didn't completely sell me on
Rose but it did sell me on the doctor
right out the gate number four the end
of the world now we're getting some
really good stuff this was a really
excellent episode to have as the second
episode because it just goes bonkers and
it throws all these aliens at you some
of which are just insane I mean the the
face of BOE a walking tree Cassandra
it's just a wonderful quirky fun mix of
creatures and aliens it's a cool setting
and immediately you know sort of gives
Rose a wake-up call for just how big the
universe is and how the world she lives
in is not eternal as much as it as much
as she has always thought it is and
again the doctor himself just gets a lot
of great moments and I like Cassandra as
a villain I like her better here than
when they decided to bring her back it
was a bit contrived but she works well I
just I do
love the irony of her character I know I
didn't rank her that I want to get my
recurring villains but that largely had
to do with her second appearance her
first one is solid and it also does a
really good job of emphasizing the
doctors life is dangerous what Rose saw
it happened to and around him that first
episode not a fluke this is how the guy
lives day to day number three bad wolf
and the parting of ways this one it had
a rough place to start out from because
the the reality and game shows parodies
at the front end of this thing don't
work for me it's one of those things it
just feels beneath a show like this it's
- it's just too goofy and I kind of just
chalk that up to first season finding a
footing in a lot of ways because stuff
like that or the garbage can eating
Mickey or the farting slily the show
kind of got over all that once it moved
on to second season and then on from
there but the way everything built up to
the reveal of the Dalek fleet the Dalek
Emperor I really loved just sort of
emphasizing that the doctor he is going
to not pull the trigger that's just not
who he is is who he absolutely does not
want to be and this episode is actually
kind of gotten better in my estimation
thanks to later episodes because at
first the whole bad wolf thing when she
takes the essence of the TARDIS into
herself I didn't like it was it was very
deus ex machina she opens up the TARDIS
and suddenly she can fix everything yeah
but sort of later nuances to that and
what you finding out her bringing back
Jack was not as good as hey you're alive
again like she she kind of did him a
disservice as she left him with a
massive burden of nearing mortality and
then with bad wolf itself particularly
in what happened with the day of the
doctor and having Rose come back as that
form really it elevated that whole thing
and it brought it all full circle to a
point that I'm now much more okay with
it going back in that early episode
number 2 Dalek how do you make a rolling
trash can with a plunger for a hand
scary this is how you do it this show
had to sell the Daleks from scratch and
the Daleks on paper are ridiculous but
this episode was so carefully
constructed
meticulously put together to emphasize
how dangerous these things are and it's
just one Dalek and it executes it
perfectly and of course just the rage
the darkness that it brings out of the
doctor and Eccleston just losing is cool
and screaming out the thing it's just a
wonderful thing it's one of the best
episodes of the show but it is not my
number one for the ninth doctor's run
that one has to go unequivocably to the
empty child and the doctor dances there
is nothing I don't love about this
episode
I love Captain Jack Harkness his
introduction and how he's used
I love how ROS sort of in a way almost
pits him and the doctor against each
other a little bit in a sort of playful
flirty way so she works for me much
better than this episode then she does
in some of her earlier ones the doctor
himself got that moment at the end of
the episode where he's begging to please
let it work and then it does and he
calls out everybody lives not only is
that a wonderful triumphant episode but
you feel the weight of all the times
when not everybody lived in the way that
he delivers that it's just phenomenal
and of course the villain the empty
child who was at the top of my one time
villains list creeped the hell out of me
it is so disturbing to me that something
that has no firm grasp of what its power
is and what it can do but can just
utterly destroy you and you know it's
it's a child set aside the alien aspect
to it just a small child doesn't have
the fully developed understanding of
life death all the morals all it knows
is just the basic guidelines of what a
parent has given it it doesn't have its
own moral Center yet so a child with the
power that that thing had that is
terrifying and just everything about
this episode I love it is one of my
favorites of any Doctor Who so that's my
ranking for the ninth doctors adventures
from worst to best
when I come back and do tenth and
eleventh Doctor it'll be more of a
legitimate top ten because in both cases
they had more than just ten stories so
what was your favorite ninth
to adventure whatever it was dropped
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned